The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK,
let's get started.
Last class, which
also means last week,
we discussed what
happens when atom
are exposed to external fields.
Well, you would
say, isn't it enough
if you understand
atoms in isolation?
Well, not quite.
Because whenever we want to
talk to the atoms, whenever
we want to manipulate them
or find out in what states
they are, we have to
apply external fields.
The way how we
communicate with atoms
is through electric, magnetic,
and electromagnetic fields.
And therefore, we
have to understand
what happens to the
structure of atoms
when we expose them
to such fields.
We started out with
structure in magnetic fields.
And if I just show
you this picture,
this is what we
discussed last week.
However, I noticed
that our discussion
with the different
coupling cases--
fine structure plus magnetic
field, hyperfine structure,
strong fields, weak fields.
I noticed that when I was
teaching, it's a lot of details
and it looks a little bit messy.
So what I want to do, therefore
at the beginning of today,
is I want to give
you sort of a summary
that you see the bigger picture.
That you see beyond the details,
that what I actually taught you
about atoms in magnetic field
is some paradigmatic example
of quantum physics.
What happens if you have two
different terms in Hamiltonian
and you have to interpolate
between one and the other?
But before I do that, do
you have any questions
about magnetic fields,
magnetic structure?
Well, then let's try to
summarize as follows.
What we have is we
have a Hamiltonian.
And it has one part, the
hyperfine interaction,
which depends on
I dot J. And then
it has an external
magnetic field part.
And what couples to the
magnetic field, which we assume
is in the J-direction--
in the z-direction
are the z-components
of the magnetic moment.
And the z-component
of the magnetic moment
are proportional to the
mJ or mI quantum number,
to the magnetic quantum number,
of the atom and the nucleus.
So in a weak field, it is
the hyperfine structure
which dominates.
So in a weak field,
we first solve
for the hyperfine structure.
And then we use
the eigenfunction
of the hyperfine structure.
And the eigenfunction of
the hyperfine structure
have the quantum number F where
J and I have coupled to F.
And then we treat the
magnetic Zeeman Hamiltonian
perturbatively.
And that led us
to the formulation
of the Lande g-factor, gF.
The other case is
the strong field case
where the magnetic
field dominates.
Then, we simply solve for
the hyperfine structure
in the magnetic field.
It's one of those rules in
quantum physics, or in physics,
or maybe even in life,
first things first.
You should first take
care of the big things.
And this is now
the magnetic field.
And since the magnetic
field Hamiltonian
is diagonalized when we
have eigenfunctions where
mJ and mI are good
quantum numbers,
this is sort of-- if you
ignore the hyperfine coupling,
this is the exact [INAUDIBLE]
of the Zeeman term.
And then in
perturbation theory, we
look for the hyperfine coupling.
And well, we do
perturbation theory
in eigenfunctions
with mI and mJ.
And that means if you
have the I dot J term,
it is only the component
mI mJ which remains.
So I've given you
those two cases.
Now, what you should also
learn here in this example
is the language which we use.
And sometimes, I would
say, the language
can be more confusing
than the equations.
What we say here is we
say that the angular
momentum of the electron
and of the nucleus
are coupled to the
magnetic field axis.
They are quantized.
The approximate
eigenstates are those
which have a specific quantum
number in the z-direction
because the magnetic field
points to the z-direction.
So we're saying I and J are
strongly coupled to the z-axis
by the magnetic field.
And then we treat
the coupling of I
and J with each other
in perturbation theory.
Whereas in the previous case,
we say I and J strongly couple.
And when I and J
strongly couple,
F becomes a good quantum number.
And that means I
and J both precess
around the axis of the
total angular momentum f.
And therefore, we say
I and J couple to F.
And then we solve for
this coupling of F
to the magnetic field
in a second step.
But I hope you see that
there's two limiting cases.
We can exactly
diagonalize one term,
and then we perturbatively
add on the result
for the second term.
Of course, in the
age of computers
I could have simply written down
for you a Hamiltonian and said,
well, it has to be
numerically diagonalized.
What I discussed instead
were the two limiting cases.
Now, this discussion
now allows me
to discuss what happens when
we go to even stronger fields.
Well, when we go to
even stronger fields,
then we may have
fields which are
even stronger than the
fine structure coupling,
the coupling of the
orbital angular momentum
of the electron and the
spin angular momentum to J.
And well, without even any
deviation, which is obvious,
you know what happens now
is that each component which
provides magnetic moment--
the spin, the orbital angular
momentum, and the nucleus-- the
dominant term for each of them
is the coupling to
the magnetic field.
So in strong magnetic fields,
these are the eigenstates.
The eigenstates are
labeled by mI, mL, mS.
So we have taken care of
the strong coupling term.
And now in addition, we are now
treating in perturbation theory
some fine structure coupling,
but the quantum numbers
are already distributed,
mL, mS. There
is a coupling
become between mI mS
and a coupling
between mI and mL.
So this is sort of
the limiting cases.
But as a general illustration
of quantum mechanics,
I thought this was a nice
example for a Hamiltonian
where we have different scalar
products, like B times S,
B dot L, S dot L, I dot J.
And the question is, how do we
take care of those
different parts
because they do not commute?
Of course, the theorist
would just say,
I simply diagonalize
it and that's it.
But if you want to
develop intuition,
then you have to discuss
the limiting cases.
And in particular, the approach
which allows an intuitive
understanding is
first things first.
And we first treat the
stronger terms and then
the weaker terms.
And we can quantitatively
derive, analytically derive
expressions, for instance,
for the Lande g-factor
in this vector model.
This vector model
assumes, so to speak,
that a state which has
an eigenfunction of mJ
rapidly precesses
around the z-axis.
And this vector
model actually allows
you to do easy
calculation without
Clebsch-Gordan coefficient.
So the concept of
the vector model
is rapid precession for
transverse components
and projecting of vectors
onto the axis around which you
have rapid precession.
But this is simply a
tool to do calculations
without the explicit use of
Clebsch-Gordan coefficients.
OK, so this is what
I wanted to tell you
about atoms in magnetic field.
Any questions?
OK then, we can actually move
onto atoms in electric field.
But before we do that, we
should have some clicker
questions about atomic
structure and atoms
comes in external
magnetic fields.
So get out the clickers.
So the first questions take us
back to electronic structure.
It's a question about,
how do wave functions,
how does density, and
how does inverse size
scale with principal
quantum number?
So the first
question is, how does
1/r, 1 over the size of the
electronic wave function,
how does it scale with n?
1/n, 1 over n squared,
1 over n cubed.
OK.
OK, yes.
It's 1 over n squared.
But I would have
hope that 100% of you
would know it because 1
over is the Coulomb energy.
The Coulomb energy is
1/2 of the total binding
energy because of
the Virial theorem.
So when you see 1/r, there
should be a flash in your head
which says energy.
And Rydberg energy
is 1 over n squared.
The energy levels of hydrogen
are 1 over n squared.
OK.
Yeah, next question.
How does psi 0 of
0 square, how does
the density of the
electron at the origin
scale with principal
quantum number?
1/n, 1 over n squared, 1
over n cubed, or 1 over n
to the sixth?
OK, yes, very good.
So what I try to
remind you here is
that there are two
different radii.
There is one radius which
scales with n squared.
But if you calculate the
density at the origin,
if you would say, well,
r scales with n squared.
The volume scales
with n to the sixth.
And then you would say
the density scales with n
to the minus 6, you're wrong.
And we had a discussion that
there are two different lengths
case in the hydrogen atom and
in hydrogenic wave function.
One scales with n squared and
the other ones scales with n.
And therefore, the density at
the origin is n to the minus 3.
Good.
Next question, from
hydrogen to helium.
In helium, for the same
electronic configuration, ,
are singlet or triplet
states more tightly bound?
So we talked about a shift
or splitting between singlet
and triplet states.
Which way does it go?
You want to try again?
For the same electronic
configuration--
the ground state has
only one configuration.
It has only one state
in the ground state.
But now we go to the excited
state, to the excited states,
and there are a number of
excited states because they
have the same
configuration, but they
can be classified by
singlet and triplet states.
OK, we are converging.
It is the triplet state.
Some people are confused when
they think about molecules.
usually, in molecules
the singlet state
is more tightly bound
than the triplet state.
But the magic word is for the
same electronic configuration.
You can have one orbital
filled with two electrons only
in a singlet state because of
the Pauli exclusion principle.
It is only in the
first excited state
or in an excited
state of a molecule
or of the helium atom that you
have two orbitals, 1s and 2s.
And you can now put the
electrons in with the same spin
or with opposite spin.
So usually, it's only
in an excited state
that the question singlet
versus triplet arises.
And then in the
excited state manifold,
the triplet state is lower
because it has a symmetric spin
wave function and anti-symmetric
spatial wave function.
OK, the next question.
OK, so we understand
now there's a difference
between triplet
and singlet state
in excited states for the
same electronic configuration.
And the question is, what is
the origin of the energy which
is splitting the singlet
from the triplet state?
Magnetic energy,
spin-spin interactions,
or electrostatic interactions?
Yes, the Coulomb interaction
is electrostatic interactions.
We discussed the singlet-triplet
splitting and the structure
of helium without any magnetic
or spin-dependent interaction.
All we had is the
Coulomb interaction.
And in the triplet state, which
is the symmetric spin state,
the spatial wave function
has to be anti-symmetric.
In the singlet state,
the spatial wave function
has to be symmetric.
And the symmetric and the
anti-symmetric spatial wave
function have a
different Coulomb energy.
So the spin through the
anti-symmetry through the Pauli
exclusion principle
determines the symmetry
of the electronic wave function.
And it is then purely
the Coulomb energy.
That's why the singlet-triplet
splitting is so big.
Because it's not magnetic,
it's Coulomb in origin.
OK, next question.
Which interaction
reflects-- oops,
maybe you want to still read it.
Which interaction reflects that
the potential between nucleus
and electron is not exactly
a Coulomb potential 1/r?
We've usually discussed
Schrodinger equation, hydrogen,
Bohr model for an
exact 1/r potential.
But then we discussed
a lot of phenomena.
And I want you to figure out
now, which of those choices
mean, in essence that you
do not have a 1/r potential?
OK, we have three choices.
So the volume isotrope
effect, I think,
is a no-brainer, is trivial.
It means explicitly
that the nucleus is not
a point, has an extended
volume, and that
means inside the nucleus
the electron is not
experiencing a 1/r potential.
So it's clear that
C is always correct.
The Lamb shift is
actually causing
a deviation from a 1/r
potential because-- well,
both the vacuum
polarization and the-- well,
you can go ahead
and say, the fact
that we have QED, that
we have other modes
of the electromagnetic
field mean
that there's a deviation
from the 1/r potential.
The interesting question
is the Darwin term.
And the people who clicked
D included the Darwin term.
That's a little bit trickier
because I explained the Darwin
term as Zitterbewegung,
as this trembling motion
of the electron which smears
out the 1/r potential.
So you would think coming
from the non-relativistic
Schrodinger equation, that
there is an effect which
is smearing out
the 1/r potential.
On the other hand,
the Zitterbewegung,
the Darwin term,
is just one term
which is included in
the Dirac equation.
And the Dirac equation,
which includes fine structure
and relativistic energy
corrections and the Darwin term
is an exact
relativistic formulation
of the 1/r potential.
So in other words, I would say
the correct answer is E. The
people who included
the Darwin term,
I would say the
Darwin term is not
a deviation of the 1/r potential
because it's simply a way
to explain what is the
result of the Dirac equation.
The Dirac equation uses
exactly the 1/r potential
without any corrections.
So you can say that if
you want to understand
the relativistic solution
to the 1/r problem,
you include a term which in
the non-relativistic equation
slightly changes the
Coulomb potential.
Questions about that?
OK.
Fine structure.
The fine structure
affects only states with L
equals 0 through
a coupling term L
dot S. Is this statement,
the way how it is written,
true of false?
I would say it's false
because the fine structure has
three contributions--
the Darwin term,
the relativistic kinetic energy
contribution, and this L dot S
term.
And it effects all
states, also the S states,
through the Darwin term
and the relativistic energy
contribution.
So the fine structure is more
than just an L dot S term.
Next question is for L equals
0, the orbiting electron
creates a magnetic field.
And spin orbit interaction
can be simply regarded
as the energy of the electron's
spin in this magnetic field.
Would you say that this
sentence is true or false?
I thought it's true,
but maybe people
want to tell me what is
false about the statement?
Maybe the first sentence
people did-- tell me,
the orbiting electron
creates a magnetic field.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I said false for
this because I normally
would picture that from the
electron's frame of reference,
the nucleus creating
a magnetic field
is the magnetic
field [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, the second part,
that there is a magnetic field
and it's been
orbiting the action is
the energy of the electron
spin in this magnetic field
is probably generally accepted.
But the first question is,
does the orbiting electron
create the magnetic field?
Well, we have the two options.
We can say the electron
moves and in its own frame
there is a v cross e term.
And therefore, magnetic field.
So we can say that the
electron's motion creates
a magnetic field
in its own frame
for the relativistic
transformation.
So in that sense, it is correct.
but I would also side
with you that there
is an alternative view of
saying in the electron's flame,
the nucleus rotates
around the electron.
And it's the nucleus which
creates the magnetic field.
In the end, it's the relative
motion between the two.
Well, isn't it a good
thing that we are not
giving scores on that?
So yes, if you
want, you everybody
can feel that you have
given the right answer.
Oh, yeah.
In Dirac-- that should
be easy, but it's just
a warm-up question for the
next one-- which states
are degenerate in Dirac theory?
And you have a few choices.
That should be easy.
Yeah, it's the S 1/2 and P 1/2.
Dirac theory does not lift
the degeneracy between states
with the same J, 1/2 and 1/2.
But between 1/2 and 3/2
states, there is, actually,
the fine structure splitting,
which we've just discussed.
OK, the next question
is, what effects lift now
the degeneracy between the 2
S 1/2 and the 2 P 1/2 term?
OK, we have three candidates--
the Lamb shift-- well, the Lamb
shift is famous and the Lamb
shift was discovered because it
splits the degeneracy
between the two.
QED corrections have different
effects on S 1/2 and P 1/2.
The size of the proton
does also shift it,
because the size of the
proton-- the volume effect
is more important for S
states than for P states.
Maybe the question is,
does the mass of the proton
lift the degeneracy?
No, it doesn't.
It would just mean if your
nucleus has a finite mass,
you simply have a
two-body problem
with a reduced mass, which is
different from the bare mass
of the electron.
But nothing else is
changed, no degeneracies.
It's as if the electron
has a different mass, which
is the effective mass.
So the correct answer here is D.
OK, four more questions.
And this is about
hyperfine structure.
So the question is, what-- well,
hydrogen in the ground state
has four states.
Because the electron has a
spin up and down and the proton
has a spin up and down.
And 2 times 2 is 4.
So we're talking about
multiplicity of 4.
And I'm asking you now about the
limits of high and low field.
First at high fields,
then at low fields.
And the question is, what
are the magnetic moments
of those hyperfine states?
And we neglect the
nuclear magneton
compared to the Bohr magneton.
So what are t magnetic moments
of those hyperfine states
in units of the Bohr magneton?
Oh, yeah.
What happens at high
magnetic fields?
Remember, at high
magnetic fields,
this is actually
the simpler case.
Often, you think the low
magnetic field is simpler
because it connects more
with the isolated atom.
But you should take
away the message
that high magnetic
fields are simple.
Because in high magnetic
field, each spin
couplets to the
magnetic field by itself
because the coupling to the
strong magnetic field-- that's
the definition of a
strong magnetic field--
is stronger than the coupling of
the two spins with each other.
So the problem I'm giving you
is that you have an electron
spin which can be
up and down and it
couples to the magnetic field.
And then we have
the nucleus spin,
but the magnetic
moment of the nucleus
is so small that we neglect it.
So what are the
possibilities now?
Well, we have four
states of hydrogen
at high magnetic field.
Two have the electron spin
up, nucleus spin up/down.
Two have the electron spin down.
And then when the nucleus
spin is up or down
in those two states.
So all the states at
high magnetic fields
have either the electron spin
up or the electron spin down.
So therefore, the
correct answer is
A. We have two states where
the electron spin is up
and two states where the
electron spin is down.
It's just a complicated
way of asking you,
what are the possible
energy levels
of an electron in
a magnetic field?
And the answer is, well,
plus-minus 1 Bohr magneton
times the magnetic field.
Questions about it?
OK.
Now, we go to the
more complicated case,
to low magnetic fields.
And again, same question.
What are the magnetic moments
of those hyperfine states?
So you have four states.
The number of states, of
course, doesn't change.
That's the dimension
of our Hilbert space.
But now we are at
low magnetic field,
and what is the
magnetic moment, which
is nothing else than the
derivative of the energy
with respect to
the magnetic field?
Yes, the correct answer is
B. We have two manifolds,
one is F equals 1,
where one slope is 0
and one slope is plus-minus 1.
And then we have an
F equals 0 state.
So it is 1, minus 1, and 0, 0.
OK.
Let's now make it
more interesting.
Let's replace the
proton by a positron,
the anti-particle
of the electron.
So now we have a similar
situation, but what happens
now is, of course,
the contribution
to the magnetic moment form
the nucleus, which is now
the positron, is as
important as the contribution
of the electron.
So you have two spin
1/2's coupled now.
One is positive,
one is negative.
And you should figure out
again, what are the energies?
But before we talk about the
energies, let's first talk
about, how many
hyperfine states do
we have in the ground
state-- 1, 2, 3, or 4?
Yes, we have four
states because we
have two particles--
positron, electron.
Each of them has
spin up, spin down.
2 times 2 is 4.
And therefore, we
have now four states.
And the question is again, at
high and low magnetic fields,
what are the magnetic
moments of those states?
So we have four
states-- spin up,
spin down-- of the
electron and the positron.
And the question is, what
are the magnetic moments
of those hyperfine states?
D is correct.
We have 1/2, spin 1/2.
If the two couple like
up-up and down-down,
we have the maximum spin.
But since one particle is
positive, one is negative,
when the spins are aligned,
the angular momenta
are anti-aligned.
And therefore, the
magnetic moment is 0.
So when they couple parallel,
the magnetic moment is 0.
When they couple anti-parallel,
the two magnetic moments
of one Bohr magneton
each add up,
and we have either 2 or minus
2 as the magnetic moment.
Any questions?
Then finally, the last question.
Same situation, positronium,
but now at low magnetic fields.
What are the magnetic moments
of the four hyperfine states
of positronium at
low magnetic field?
All right.
Let's discuss it.
What is the structure
of the ground
state at low magnetic field?
What is the good quantum
number at low magnetic field?
AUDIENCE: F.
PROFESSOR: F. It's hydrogen.
It's like hydrogen.
1/2 and 1/2.
If we have an S of 1/2 of the
electron, the I of the positron
is also 1/2.
And 1/2 and 1/2 couple to F.
And what are the values for F?
F equals 1 and F equals 0.
OK, what is the magnetic
moment of the F equals 1 state?
In order to get F equals
1 out of 1/2 and 1/2,
you have to align the spin of
the electron with the positron.
So the F equals 1/2
state is the state where
the two spins are aligned.
What is the magnetic
moment or this state?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0.
How many states are in
the F equals 1 manifold?
What's a multiplicity
of F equals 1?
3.
Plus, minus 1 and 0.
So we have an F
equals 1 state which
has angular momentum
but no magnetic moment,
and it has a multiplicity of 3.
So three states have
0, 0 magnetic moment.
In other words, you
would expect an F equals
1 state to have this
kind of Zeeman structure.
But because of the special
situation in positronium,
the Zeeman structure
is like this.
There is no linear effect.
It's a quadratic effect.
All three states
start out with 0 slope
because as long as the
spins couple to F equals 1
and we don't have a
magnetic field messing up
with the coupling, the
magnetic moment is 0.
OK, now what happens in the
fourth state, which is F
equals 0?
In the fourth state,
which is F equals 0,
the two spins couple in
an anti-parallel way.
So now, what is
the magnetic moment
when the two spins couple
in an anti-parallel way?
The spins subtract.
But because of the different
charge, plus and minus,
the magnetic moments
would add up.
That's what we just discussed
in the high field case.
So you would think the F equals
0 state has a magnetic moment.
But in an F equals 0 state,
it cannot point anywhere
because the angular
momentum is 0.
And therefore, in a most
trivial way, this is hydrogen
and this is positronium.
So positronium has
four hyperfine states.
And the slope of all four,
for the reasons discussed,
is all 0.
So sorry, A is the correct
answer, without any ambiguity
this time.
OK.
Any questions?
OK, then let's talk about
atoms in electric field.
We start out in--
we put the atoms
in a uniform electric field.
Again, we assume that it
points in the z-direction
and its magnitude is epsilon.
And we want to ask, what
is the electrostatic energy
in this electric field?
And we are using the fact
that electrostatic energy can
be expanded in a
multi-pole expansion.
We have a monopole term,
we have a dipole term,
and we have a quadratic term.
So the charge, of course,
is-- the atom, itself,
is a neutral atom.
So there is no monopole term.
The linear term in
the electric field
would correspond to a
permanent dipole moment.
And I will remind you in
a moment that this is 0.
And then the term which
provides us with a stark effect,
with the energy shift of
atoms in electric field will
be the third term here,
which is characterized
by the polarizability alpha.
And it corresponds to an
induced dipole moment.
That there is an
induced dipole moment,
which is alpha times epsilon.
And then the induced
dipole moment
interacts with the
electric field.
And that gives then, epsilon
times epsilon-- epsilon
squared.
So this would be a classical
multi-pole expansion.
And we will now derive
results quantum mechanically.
The perturbation operator for
us is the dipole operator.
And that could, in
principle, include
a permanent or an
induced dipole moment.
So it would take care of
the second and third term,
the dipole operator and its
projection on the z-axis.
So the dipole
operator is the charge
of the electron
times the position.
And as long as
the polarizability
and the situation is isotropic.
A minus sign.
Minus E is the charge.
If you apply an electric
field in the z-direction,
all the relevant dipole
moments are in the z-direction.
For anisotropic materials, you
could have an electric field
in the z-direction and
the dipole moment points
at an angle, but we do not have
such a situation for our atoms.
OK, so the operator
is then simply
charge of the electron,
the z-coordinate times
the electric field.
And this has o parity.
And that leads us
immediate to the result
when we have an atom
in an eigenstate n
and we ask, what is the
expectation value of H prime?
It is 0 because of parity.
So the answer is, we
have no permanent dipole
moment until we have
degenerate energy levels.
If n is a non-degenerate
level, this matrix element
is 0 by the parity
selection rule.
OK, now we want to do
perturbation theory.
So our perturbation
operator is this.
And since we have
the clickers, I just
want to ask you two
quick questions.
I will do the
perturbation theory
and I will explain
everything, but maybe you
want to predict
the result, which
I want to derive in
the next 10 minutes.
And the question is,
what will we actually
get for the expectation
value of H prime?
Will we get the expectation
value of the dipole operator
times the electric
field or will we
get the expectation value
of the dipole operator
times the electric field over 2?
And the next question
would be the same,
but what do we get for
the total Hamiltonian?
So these are the questions.
I want to discuss with you
in the next 10 minutes,
simply using perturbation
theory, expectation values.
Expectation values of the total
energy each, not plus H prime.
But also, expectation values
of the electrostatic energy,
which is H prime.
And the question
is-- I mean, you
can say for
dimensionless units, what
we get is a dipole moment
times an electric field.
And this is one of the
situation where factors of 1/2
are not just bookkeeping.
Factors of 1/2 really
reflect interesting physics.
And I want to sort of
highlight it by asking you,
what would you
expect what we get
for those expectation values
when we solve for atomic energy
levels in electric fields?
So we're discussing
first question 1.
OK, let's go to question 2.
OK.
Anyway, now I know
I'm not boring you
with the derivation I want
to give you in the next 10
minutes.
I want to give you
the answer right away
by drawing up
another problem where
maybe the answer
is more intuitive.
And this is we have a mass on a
spring with spring constant k.
And now the equivalent
to the electric field
which we switch on is--
we switch on gravity.
And due to gravity, the object
zags by an amount delta z.
So the question is,
what is-- and delta z
is like the dipole moment.
What is the gravitational
energy gained by the object
because it has fallen down?
It is zagging down
due to gravity.
Well, I think you would
agree that the answer is,
it is mg times delta z.
This is the work done by
gravity with a minus sign.
So the expectation value of
the perturbation operator
is minus mg times delta z.
Or in electrostatic
units, it's simply
the dipole moment times
the electric field.
But what happens is the-- so
this is gravitational energy.
How much is the
total energy affected
when we switch on the
gravitational field?
1/2 of it, because
the negative energy
which is gained in the
gravitational field, 1/2 of it
is used to stretch the spring.
1/2 of it goes into the
internal energy of the system.
So therefore, the electrostatic
energy H prime-- H prime
is the operator of the
electrostatic energy.
The answer here is A.
But the total energy
is B because part
of the energy is
needed to stretch the spring.
And as I want to show
you, stretching the spring
is-- we admix to the ground
state some excited state.
This costs energy, like
stretching the spring costs
energy.
And this is responsible for the
fact of which is exactly 1/2.
Well, I could stop here.
I think I've explained
it all, but let's follow
the usual-- the
standard approach.
And let's do second-order
perturbation theory
and calculate the energy,
calculate the dipole moment,
and see that everything
is as we expect now.
So we want to do second-order
perturbation theory.
We know already the
first-order term is 0.
This was a discussion
about parity.
And in second-order
perturbation theory,
the state n has an energy,
which is the unperturbed energy.
And then in second-order,
we have the matrix element
to all other states.
We square it.
We divide by the
energy denominator.
We sum over all states m,
but I make a prime here.
Of course, we are
not summing over
the state-- we exclude
n from the summation.
And the prefactor here
is electron charge
squared times electric
field squared.
OK, pretty much
that's the resulting
second-order
perturbation theory.
So this is the
energy and we want
to relate the energy
to the dipole moment.
So the next step is
now we calculate d.
and we calculate d from the
first-order wave function
because we already get an effect
in first order and everything
here is about leading order.
So the expectation value
of the dipole operator--
so we take the expectation value
of the dipole operator and we
use the 0-th order,
the unperturbed state,
plus the first-order correction.
And we know already that
the diagonal terms do not
contribute.
This is a parity selection rule.
So we get contributions
from the course term,
which is n0 the dipole
operator with n1.
So let's just suppress
vectorial notation.
We know everything
is along the z-axis.
So we have the 0-th
order wave function.
Our operator is z.
And now we have to write down
the first-order correction
to the wave function.
And the first-order
correction is
the sum over all other states.
We make an admixture
of the state m,
and this admixture
uses a matrix element.
And here, we have the
energy denominator.
So what we obtain is-- we
have the electron charge here
from the dipole moment.
We have the electron charge due
to the perturbation operator.
So it's electron squared.
We have the electric field.
And then, this is due to
the admixture of the wave
function with the
dipole operator.
And now because we
take the matrix element
of the dipole operator,
we get another occurrence
of the dipole operator.
So therefore, we do first-order
perturbation theory,
but we take the
first-order result
and ask, what is the expectation
value for the dipole moment?
And that means the
dipole operator,
or the perturbation
operator appears twice.
And our result is as expected.
Quadratic in the
matrix element and it
has this energy denominator.
So the definition is that
a dipole moment is alpha
times the electric field.
So therefore, all
that equals alpha.
And if you compare now the
result for the dipole moment
with the second-order
perturbation
theory for the electric
field, for the energy,
we find-- here's a factor of
2, but there is no factor of 2
up there.
We find that the energy or
the energy shift delta En,
it has exactly the same matrix
element as the polarizability.
It is-- yes.
It is this, 1/2 alpha
epsilon squared.
Since the perturbation operator,
I'm just writing it down here,
was dipole moment
times electron,
that means that the
energy shift is-- and this
is what we expected
now, is 1/2 times
the expectation value
of the dipole moment
times the electric field.
So now we have obtained with a
quantum mechanical calculation
the result.
I told you that the energy
shift of the energy levels
is 1/2 the dipole moment
times the electric field.
Let me just redo the
calculation in a way I like.
And this is I want to
determine now the total energy,
but sort the terms in a
little bit different way.
So I want to know, what is
the energy in our result?
And what we do is we are
calculating the energy
using our wave functions.
We take the total Hamiltonian
and take the wave function.
So this leads us to three terms.
One is the unperturbed energy.
The unperturbed energy,
the energy contribution
of the first-order correction.
This is the part due to H0.
And the part due to
H prime is simply
the dipole moment times
the electric field.
So the first part is, of
course, simply the energy E0
times the norm of
the wave function n0.
For the second term, we use the
first-order perturbation theory
for n1.
This is our sum over m.
Em minus E0.
m H prime 0.
Because n1 is on
either side, this
is the amplitude
of the state n1.
We have to square it.
And since we calculate what is
the expectation value of H0,
we multiply with the energy Em.
OK, so we are done.
We calculate the total energy.
We get three terms.
One is the unperturbed
energy, one
is the dipole energy
in the electric field,
and one is the extra term,
which I want to discuss.
Actually, this term is
the internal energy,
which would correspond
to the stretching
of the spring in Hooke's law.
Now, in order to show
it to you explicitly,
I want to use E0 equal
0 for the energy.
Because then this term is 0.
I can neglect this.
And one of the squares,
1 over Em squared,
cancels with the Em.
It confused me for a while.
If I don't set E0 to 0,
the result looks different.
But what happens is, if
you do perturbation theory,
there are certain issues with
the normalization of the wave
function.
And the wave function
n0 has to be--
the contribution if
you look at the wave
function in perturbation
theory of a state,
the 0-th order wave function
has an amplitude of 1.
And this amplitude of 1 only
changes in second order.
So since I'm doing a
second-order calculation here,
I have to include those
non-standard terms.
But I can also bypass
it by setting E0 to 0,
then the second-order term
in the norm doesn't matter.
So in other words,
if you set E0 to 0,
you make your life easier.
If you do not set
E0 to 0, you have
to include some more
terms in your calculation.
But the result is--
just one second.
But yeah, the result which
I wanted to emphasize
is this one here.
It is a positive energy.
You can immediately inspect
that t positive energy
is the dipole moment times
the electric field over 2.
This is exactly
analogous to the energy
of the spring in the
gravitational problem.
So in other words, this is
the energy, internal energy,
because we admix excited
states to the ground state.
This crosses energy
and it exactly
accounts for the occurrence
of the factors of 1/2.
Anyway, this is just
the standard theory
of the DC stark effect of
the atomic polarizability,
but I put a little
bit of emphasis
on those factors
of 1/2 and tried
to explain in greater
detail the contributions
to the AC stark effect--
to the DC stark effect
which come from the
electrostatic energy
and which come from
the internal energy.
Questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I have a study question.
What is allowing you to use
non-degenerate perturbation
theory?
What's the operator
that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well,
I'm looking-- what
allows me to do non-degenerate
perturbation theory.
Well, I assume we don't
have degeneracies.
If you would go to very high
Rydberg states-- and actually,
we do that not today,
but on Monday-- we
are looking at a situation where
the splitting between states
of different L become so small
that the electric field mixes
them.
Then, we have to do degenerate
perturbation theory.
And that means we get
now a linear term,
linear stark effect, not
a quadratic stark effect.
Here, I would say we
are doing perturbation
theory of the ground state.
It's an S state.
It's not degenerate.
Maybe your question
is also addressing,
but we have multiple
ground states.
We have hyperfine structure.
However, the electronics--
the stark effect,
the electric field does not
couple to the spin at all.
So therefore, all the
magnetic energies--
the hyperfine energies
are completely unaffected.
And also, if we apply
an electric field,
all the hyperfine states
experience the same shift
and there is no
coupling between them.
So also, we have
multiple ground states.
We have hyperfine structure.
It's a non-degenerate
problem because there
is no coupling between the
different hyperfine states.
In other words, the theory
or the discussion of the DC
stark shift is you
have an S state,
you couple with
an electric field,
and there is no
degeneracy in the S state.
Other questions?
Well, then we've
talked about alpha.
The only parameter which comes
out of this treatment is alpha.
And now we want to
discuss, how big is alpha?
Or first, what are
the units of alpha?
Well, the units of alpha
were-- you can go back
to the second-order
perturbation result.
But the units of alpha were
the charge, time [INAUDIBLE].
This was the dipole operator.
It was squared.
And in perturbation theory,
we divided by energy
because we had an
energy denominator.
Well, we can write that as q
squared over l times l cubed.
But q squared over l
is the Coulomb energy.
And therefore, when I'm
interested in the units,
the units cancel.
So therefore, we find that the
unit of the polarizability,
at least in [INAUDIBLE]
unit or atomic units, which
I've chosen here, is
simply the volume.
The question is, what volume?
Well, if you would calculate
the polarizability for hydrogen,
and simply make the assumption
that the only important matrix
element goes from
the S to the P state,
then we have a matrix element
which is on the order of
[INAUDIBLE].
And the energy splitting
between the first ground state
and first excited
state is three quarter
of the Rydberg constant.
So for hydrogen in the 1s state,
if you only use the coupling
to the 2p state, we find that
alpha is the Bohr radius cubed.
And the prefactor is 2.96.
If you do the summation
over all states,
the prefactor would
be 4.5 because there
are higher states, especially
continuum states, which
contribute to the sum.
We have only five
minutes left, but that
allows me to show you that this
is not a coincidence that we
obtain-- here, what we obtain
is the Bohr radius cubed, which
is pretty much the volume
of the hydrogen atom.
But we can now do
an approximation.
It's not really relevant,
but it has an historic name--
[INAUDIBLE] approximation.
It's just nice to show
how things work out.
We have a second-order
matrix element,
so we couple the state n with
the operator z to a state m.
But if we assume that all energy
denominators can be taken out
of the summation by
assuming that we have
some kind of average
excited energy,
then the sum of--
maybe I should have
said it the sum m z
n, which we sum over m
and it just cancels out.
So what we have is, if
you take the energy,
an average energy denominator
out of the summation,
what we find is
that what matters
is the matrix element z squared.
And we can even assume that
in the energy denominator,
the excited state
energy is negligible.
The hydrogen atom has a
binding energy of 1 Rydberg
and the first excited state
has a quarter Rydberg.
So at the 25% level,
we can set that to 0.
So I'm waving all my hands, but
I'm getting a simple expression
for the polarizability
in the ground state.
And this goes as follows--
the ground state energy is--
we have discussed
Coulomb energy, Virial's
theorem, and all that.
We need just 1/r in
the ground state.
And for the z squared
matrix element,
we can simply say for
an S state that it
is x squared y
squared z squared.
It is 1/2 of r squared
in the ground state.
So therefore, continuously
waving our hands
and making approximations, we
find that the polarizability
is r squared expectation
value divided by an r
to the minus expectation value.
So this is some r
cubed expectation
value which is an atomic value.
So you see the nature of
the perturbation expression
suggests that cannot be anything
else than the atomic volume.
I sort of like that because when
people discuss, for instance
in my group, does
lithium or rubidium
have a bigger polarizability?
Well, the bigger atom
has a bigger volume
and the more fluffier atoms
have the larger polarizability.
And that's pretty much
based on that result.
Now, let me finally
do a comparison.
There is another
system for which
you have done calculations
of the dipole moment.
And this is in classical E
and M for conducting sphere.
For conducting [INAUDIBLE]
electric field,
you can exactly solve
the boundary conditions,
the boundary value problem,
get the electric field,
and find the dipole moment.
And the exact result is
that the dipole moment
is the electric field times
the cube of the sphere.
So in other words, the dipole
moment, or the polarizability
of this sphere,
is-- and neglecting
factors, which are
only factors of unity.
The dipole moment-- sorry, the
polarizability of a conducting
sphere is the volume
of the sphere.
The dipole moment
of a hydrogen atom,
or using [INAUDIBLE]
approximation
for all simple atoms is
the volume of the atom.
So I find it sort of
interesting that when
it comes to dipole moments
and to polarizability,
that atoms pretty
much behave like
metallic-conducting
spheres of the same volume.
Any questions?
OK, then let's stop here
and we meet again on Monday.